we we took a little trip through the
barstool content Factory and that was
that was cool
shout out barstool they were everyone
was really cool a lot cooler than I
think I was expecting I didn't I didn't
know what to expect I mean I obviously I
know if part of my take but like I
thought the rest of it was gonna be like
douche bag Factory yeah I thought there
was gonna be like just mega tools yeah
no offense beast tool if you're watching
yeah yeah nobody you know fence it hi
yes I just being honest I didn't know
what to expect
yeah I mean it's tough one like when
when you associate a bar stool with just
like the the meme Instagram account yeah
that's all it is yeah that's all I know
from barstool is like frat dudes
forwarding memes back and forth yeah but
uh people like you know shotgunning
white Claus or whatever the [ __ ] but no
it was it was awesome everyone there was
super nice and really funny I'd like I
totally understand now why why they're
those shows are so successful because
everyone was really charismatic and it
was easy to although shows I want to
give a big shout-out to um our boys at
KFC radio for diving deep on Adrianna
chech Nick yeah that was great
I I got I got the boy to dry-heave which
I guess is um is a bit of a bit of a
skill you want to explain this for
people that aren't gonna go watch it so
basically we got talking about Adrianna
Chetnik who is the girl that we
referenced towards the end of the year
say that that she had that squirting
video go viral she's an adult she's in
the film actress yeah she's an adult
performer she does stunts yeah and her
and her her big her hottest release at
the top of the year was a the squirting
on an escalator bit she was Phi it's got
like nine thousand downloads on death
here [ __ ] bangs and so we didn't really
get her name right so the boys at KFC
were like now you you got to put some
respect on her name get her damn name
right it's Adriana chech Nick was like
oh I'm sorry but then we they knew it
like they they're big fans yeah we were
surprised that they even knew of that
video oh yeah everybody thought that was
kind of like a niche little little like
video you know the
one of those porn videos you find on
Twitter we were like yeah and you send
it like one person yeah and I was
impressive they even dug that up out of
us and and so we got talking about it
and and so I proceeded to make a joke
about a genetic tipping like like on on
Ash Wednesday when the priest goes
around with the palm leaf and he dips it
in the holy water and he's sprinkling
the crowd I made a joke that she was
gonna do the same thing with her sport
water water juice our boy caves he just
stood up and just [ __ ] he started he
just instantly he starts to chuckling
he's like like so hard and loud and
we're like are you dying are you good
started getting turned on with how hard
he was dry heaving that [ __ ] was like
damn bruh he stands up laughs even more
than goes he dry heaved hard and then
he's like he's like I almost got it down
almost got it really what's what's
happening yeah he does this all the time
he's got a really sensitive stomach I
was crying
him if you go back and watch I mean Cody
and I are like just wiping our eyes like
they started moving on to another
subject and I wasn't ready I was like
what [ __ ] was crazy what was the story
you told me about your friend oh yeah
yeah oh boy he had a sensitive stomach
in elementary school and like he would
puke real easy even through college was
a little bit like that we got him to
puke one time in a parking lot it was so
funny funny somebody like hocked a
loogie and then he was like Oprah and
then everyone just started doing it we
got him to puke just from hocking
loogies and he's like bro stop stop bro
seriously though knock it off
you like stepped away and yeah but no no
that's not the story the main story was
that in elementary school a kid sat in a
slice of pizza and the kid stood up yeah
and it was like a perfectly like just
mushed Pizza into the kids at like pants
and for some reason that triggered my
boy and he just puke instantly like you
just saw he's just do that's so funny
because that's not gross at all no it's
not there's nothing gross about sitting
in pizza it's just like ah it sucks like
I watch pants now but it's not gross
even though sentence I just said in
pizza you said perfectly perfectly
smushed pizza when they look perfectly
smooshed like I don't know like it just
like it like just like mesh to his pants
like it's tough it's like like so funny
for some reason there's just enough
resistance in the pizza slice that had
just stayed right on his ass cheek damn
you got that perfectly smudged yeah tena
who sat on that perfectly okay cuz I'm
maybe like you could have sat on it
wrong it could have fell he didn't slide
at all there was no way there is no yeah
there's no like snail trail perfect
[Laughter]
throwing up is so funny yo check out
that big let's guide you sat on some
pizza
[Music]